huge as we cover the coronavirus we
should remember that food insecurity or
the lack of food
that is another impact of the pandemic
the demand here in southern nevada has
doubled basically since the start of
everything we have seen emergency food
distribution sites pop up all across the
valley
school campuses casino parking lots at
the start of the pandemic southern
nevada had about a 12 percent
food insecurity rate that's about 270
000 people across the valley who just
don't know where their next meal is
coming from
but now that number is pushing closer to
450
000 even as things open back up
those who fall into food security
usually
stay there for an extended period of
time it takes longer for them to get out
of that
while the hospitality industry has taken
a huge hit as we all know three square
says
its partners in the casino industry they
are still donating funds and food
if you at home are in the position to
help three square can provide
three meals for every dollar that's
donated we have more information on that
and of course the donation sites
over at eight newsnow dot com